okay hey everyone it's my vatos and
welcome to the order flows market
analysis for Friday September 8th and
market was kind of quiet I think as you
know everyone is sort of focusing on the
impact of Hurricane ARMA that's affected
to reach landfall in Florida over the
weekend I think it's Sunday at 2:00 p.m.
I saw anyway the market said it's been
rallying quite nicely for the week is
gold Gold's up 1.7 percent for the week
1352 equities kind of mixed kind of mix
I think we had a small gain in the Dow
but you know for the week the Dow is
down just under 1% so let's take a look
at some of these markets there was some
interesting things actually my I'm
overseas right now and the power went
out here at about I think the time I was
around I was going off and on here you
know cuz we also got a heavy storm in
the Philippines right now and you know
being the third world sometimes when
there's very very heavy rains they shut
down the power grid in case you know
they don't the lines to fall over and
start fires and stuff like that so
around 11:30 p.m. last night
- at 11:30 a.m. in you know Chicago time
you know my I lost everything
as far as data I mean you know I my
connection got cut off even the internet
was known so I this will sort of be a
morning recap because I don't have the
afternoon data but anyway this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only should not
be considered a solicitation to buy or
sell a futures contract or make any
other type of investment decision future
strain contain essential risk and it's
not for every investor an investor could
potentially lose all are more than the
initial investment risk capital is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be user
training and only those were sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past reports it's not necessarily
indicative of future results again you
know that the tools I use in this
presentation are the order flows trader
volume footprint chart the Delta scalper
which is a tool additional tool and the
price rejector which is also additional
tool Delta scalper and price rejector
are order flow tools to read the order
flow and you know basically help you in
your trading decisions you know again
you know order flow is is a bit complex
when you know for new for beginners and
it takes
honestly it takes time it's not
something that's cut and dry there's so
many different facets of order flow that
you know for a beginner it's gonna take
some time you know but that's why I
record these videos that's why I make
these videos and you know that's why I
have a course on order flow so that you
can understand what you're what you're
looking at you know I mean you look at
an order flow chart this is an order
flow chart right here and and to be
honest you know for the uninitiated it's
it's a bit confusing you know you have
numbers a lot of numbers people see
numbers you get scared of numbers you
know fear of numbers and but it's really
very simple right the volume it's on the
right-hand side is the volume of the
trades on the offer the volume traded on
the left hand side is the volume traded
on the bid and you know without getting
into a little bit more just talking
about this is the British Pound this is
the eight range chart I like range
charts as opposed to minute based charts
but I do look at minute phase charts as
well but the reason why I prefer range
based charts is because I like to see
how price moves you know from a level to
a level rather than oh it's 9:15 time to
start a new bar like that so early on in
the morning British Pound you had Delta
scalper gave you a sell then it came
right back you know two bars later with
a nice with the buy I'll say a nice buy
but you know you have a short
opportunity here right off the high this
Green Line is the high but then it comes
right back you got to buy very very fast
you know within two bars which is a
bullish sign as well and so now you're
looking at it initially you're thinking
hey this market can sell off but then
boom you get a reversal sign here that
this market is not selling off in fact
it's you got aggressive buyers coming
back up as you're coming into the high
what Delta does it tells you the
difference between net aggressive buyers
and aggressive sellers so is that
important well yeah when you're at highs
or lows you want to know is this high
going to hold is this low gonna hold or
are we going to go higher or we're going
to go lower and if you're seeing signs
up near the high of aggressive selling
like you saw here early you know right
off the high you know you're thinking
hey this markets gonna sell off but then
lo and behold what do you see again you
know you're up here you see a lot of
negative Delta's from in here right
which is bearish right that aggressive
selling up here at the high but you know
what the Delta scalpers read you know
this Delta all these numbers here stop
line here and it's telling you real hold
on you know this is possibly a fake fake
out and you're seeing aggressive buying
starting to come back in and if you're
seen aggressive buy and come back in
near a high chances are you know there's
a good chance we can take out the high
and potentially keep going higher so our
high here earlier was at 53 Delta
scalper gives you the buy signal you
take out the high you got a divergence
that fails the next bar up here takes it
out so you're you know you should be
looking to be getting along as you're
taking off as high you know at 54 and we
keep trading up up up you see aggressive
buying you see buying imbalances in
these bars up up up more buying then you
can up here you have the Delta scalper
given you a sell this is so you went
from 50 down here 131 you know 54 53 to
where where you get your sell signal up
here in the 90s so you know you probably
had another divergence here actually
so you got one divergence that failed
here did you have any earlier not really
so you're looking at two filled
divergences but then you get in this
well you don't know this one's failed
yet you're looking at this Delta scalper
you got a divergence thinking hey you
know maybe this markets gonna sell off
so you know you're long from 53 54
you're trading up here you know in the
90s 80s up in here you know maybe take
it off maybe you lighten it up but then
you got definitely you got a sell signal
here you so you should be out of that
position and then what does the market
do comes right back up with a bullish
bar you got imbalance and balancing
balancing balance for imbalances in the
bar you take out the high you start
seeing again an aggressive buy and come
in with more buying and balances boom
boom boom
start taking off the high you get up
here to 21 which is your new high you
got a divergence again but again you
know that's at this time it's 656 you
know your first divergence was down here
at 4:00 in the morning for 39 is it's a
bit long I mean yeah you know and when I
see groupings of divergences that fail I
do think the markets going higher but
again you had just a very big move
already you had a
you know basically a 50 point 70 point
move up here you know start thinking
that you know hey we're gonna still keep
going higher yes we can and you see we
do we get up to 27 then you start
selling off but again you know if when
you when you're playing break outs right
you don't want to be playing break outs
after you know you just had a great
breakout right you break out the time to
play it was down here you know at 4:00
in the morning ideally you know look for
signs not after you rally from 50 all
the way up to you know 130 150 all the
way all the way up to you know 130 221
that's a 70 tick move don't be looking
for breakouts up here because that's not
you've already broken out right you know
it'd be better if you we have a you know
a reason we buying a breakout up here
like maybe at 60 or at 70 or obviously
somewhere down here at the right before
the initial breakout or right around the
initial breakout not after you broke out
and move 70 ticks so we come off it's
not coming off you got your ratio and
your divergence here's the thirty four
point two five here's your divergence
which is a bearish sign you kind of go
slow sideways over the next you know 45
minutes stacks selling and balance right
in here you can see and you sell off a
bit more down down to the swing low then
this is where my data stopped here so
that was the British Pound look at Jeff
yen really quick here Japanese yen was a
bit interesting though there's some nice
signals in the order flow with with
Delta scalper and price rejector now
let's say you know when I'm not
necessarily one to say that you know
when you have Delta scalper and price
rejector you know when you got like a
confluence of things it makes the signal
stronger no I don't think it makes a
signal stronger but I do like it you
know it's not like I don't put plus one
plus one plus one you know like when I
have divergence Delta scalper price
rejector and think all this is 10 times
stronger or 30 times stronger because
you got you know everything no I still
like it you know I just you know I've
seen them we got everything aligned up
and then the trade fails you know again
I
think it person I don't add any extra
when you call it power so to speak to
the move rather I still like the move so
this is at 3:00 in the morning and your
high here in the Jackie n God divergents
got the negative Delta you got the price
rejecter
you've got the Delta scalper and this is
what it around 90 to 80 down here next
bar getting short around I'm sorry not
90 to 80 I can't read
90 to 97 90 to 95 and this next bar is
PI where you're getting short trades all
the way down to 85 this is where you get
the next single signal this is the
u-turn giving you a buy signal you start
rallying back up you have a stack buying
and balance here just below the high
honestly I prefer the stacked behind and
balances on the other side of the high
not going up into the high well that's
just neat then you get up here again you
got a divergence no ratio next bar you
got the ratio you settle off not not a
big sell-off about 10 ticks then you
just kind of go sideways here you got
the delta scalper giving you a sell
unfortunately it doesn't work out it
makes a new high up here again you got a
ratio and divergence do you sell off
need over the next this is what times
606 over the next hour you're sort of
going sideways here before you start
rallying back up now you know you're
getting short here right at 13 and then
over the next hour you're still trading
right around there
and that's not a good sign that this
trade is gonna work out yeah it might
but again you know you should have a
time stop thinking in terms of time
because you know one it's eating up your
capital I'll say eating it up in the
terms of you know you've got a position
on that's going nowhere you're not
getting paid and - it's eating up your
mental thoughts you know you're thinking
you're in this trade it's going nowhere
sitting there going back and forth what
do i do what do i do and you're not
looking at other markets other
opportunities that are presenting
themselves because you're sort of stuck
in this position right it's like being
in a bad relationship you know being in
a relationship that's going nowhere you
know it's not going to lead to marriage
you don't want to break up it's just one
of these things going sideways you know
eventually you got to pull the plug and
you know this this you know a physician
like this is the same thing you got
point of controls
one two three four these are right
around the same level so you know you're
just going sideways here you know get
out get out and let the market tell you
you know what you should do now you get
up here you got a new high you've got a
divergent it's not a racial it's
borderline actually is twenty seven
point six seven I like twenty eight you
know the market sells off off this high
and the important control also up near
at the top of the bar it's in the second
slot you can see here you got the POC
trader this aqua line giving you that
sign that hey you know there's some
resistance up there and you know in this
market now it made the nice the nice
move lower you know down down down down
down down under pressure all day here's
the Delta scalper that failed here was a
nice little signal with the red arrow
and this bar you know this is a unique
indicator unique to order closed trader
tells you trap traders up here in the
top of this bar and you see over the
next couple of bars it sells off now
when you're dealing with trapped traders
right trapped traders is going to be
more of a short-term move don't look for
trapped traders to be a long-term move
thinking like oh I had trapped traders
here and you hold in position for you
know 30 minutes know you have trapped
traders you know the reason why they
call it trapped traders is because
they're stuck in a position that's not
working out so the people that bought as
you're going up here you know going up
here think we're gonna break out I mean
look at this volume up in here you know
205 158 170 140 you're coming up here
and you know these guys everyone that
was piling in here buying it I'll son
they're stuck so what they gotta do you
know they're gonna sell they're not
gonna sell an hour later when you think
of trapped traders it's people that are
long and wrong in this case they're
gonna get out soon sooner rather than
later
you know trapped traders are more of you
know the the short-term scalper type
traders that you know are buying it and
they realize that wrong and get out
really fast it's it's not people that
are buying it you know and they've got
you know 50 points tops you know they're
buying it they are people that got very
tight stops and as soon as they realize
the trade is not working out they get
out
here's a delta scalper that failed
there's no other way to put it we sell
off we sell off we get down here and not
really much in there to talk about in
the order flow then you get up into this
area up here our 925 you get this big
doji bar up here on the top all the
candlestick er oh yeah don't you bar
there you're supposed to sell you know
even though they you know they don't
tell you that you know they tell you
after the fact you know they don't they
don't tell you that oh it's a mark sign
of market incision you know I mean you
can stop there and still go higher but
anyway you know what the order flow it's
a little bit more clear you got stack
selling imbalances in here next bar is
up but then the next bar again more
selling coming in so you know just by
looking at this this markets gonna fall
over and what does it do it falls over
trades down from you know 73-74 area
right down directly down into the 60s
and you just sort of hanging around here
you've got was that point of control
trader here giving you the buy signal
you got racial bonds low point control
on the bottom a rally up here to the
price rejecter again trap traders sign
you have a trap traders you have this
move up I mean look at this volume up
here 194 109 182 the next bar down you
know again if you're a short-term trader
like trying to get the next few ticks
you know trap traders is something that
you know you should look into and then
you just sort of go sideways and start
working away back up here this is rod
word my data ended for the day I don't
know what else happened the rest of this
day but anyway that was the Japanese yen
okay let's take a look at equities you
know equities ended mixed for the day
there's still some moves really quick on
the 10 range S&P chart you know this is
the low here at 649 you got the price
rejector giving you a buy signal and you
know over the next couple hours
this is 649 until 843 two hours later
it's just kind of going spinning its
wheels before it makes the move up but
again you know if you're trading a ten
range chart your outlook is going to be
a lot
longer than and say you're trading a for
range chart so you know you can take it
an hour or two in the in a ten range
whereas in a four range you shouldn't be
holding a position for an hour because
it's a faster-moving chart then you get
the price rejecter here doesn't so you
know you get your price rejecter from
your low down in here so you're in your
binder on fifty-seven something and then
price rejected up here so you know maybe
you're selling it around sixty this one
fails the cell the cell fails but at
anyway I said you know might my data
just goes up to this one bar here so I
think I look at the four range despite a
little bit more revealing there's some
interesting things we can talk about in
the four range if I can find it here
looks it's bear with me here
that's like can't find the chart when
you need it and then hope I didn't close
it down but to do my eyes closed its
yeah quite upset but you know anyway
it's rollover week started in emini so
you should be looking at December not
September in case you haven't updated
your charts just on get that out there
for you guys but again y'all so 609 this
was that low here you see the price
rejecter
you know price rejecter work the best on
lows and highs not necessarily in the
middle of training like this one here is
you know we're not on our lower off our
low still but you know when it appears
right on the low and the high it's it's
quite powerful so here you got it on the
low of the day you got a divergence no
ratio and X bar you got the ratio you
like and you get a nice move you know so
even if you're not convinced with this
price rejector here you're next bar you
got the ratio and the divergence so you
know I say you get along around fifty
seven fifty seven and a half it makes a
move up to 59 59 and a half this is a
price rejector giving you a cell and you
know you sell off a bit get down here
pointing control towards the bottom you
know again and in you got a bullish
ratio you rally back up to a bar where
you got point of control
that's this aqua line it's telling me
that's it there's a very useful point of
control for trading
this one just sort of goes sideways this
bar here I I thought was going to be
very bearish I thought we're gonna sell
off this bar but we didn't again porter
controlled near the high you got these
imbalances here you got you know some
buying here that you couldn't follow
through you got buying and balance
finding a balance behind and balance and
you didn't follow through and you came
right back really quick made a new high
up here i got an opponent interested
prominent pointed control up here and we
sort of held that one and started
working our way back down here you got a
stacked imbalance
that you just went sideways on again you
know I say you know by the time you get
to the the third bar if you're still
hanging around that imbalance area it's
probably not gonna be very effective
fourth bar you'll get on the other side
of it fifth bar still there and in this
case it just kept going sideways then
you know went higher I mean you know
they think was yesterday there was one
where you had that imbalance you know
you're just hanging around hanging
around and then you sold off but you
know really it's losing its
effectiveness as time goes on you know
these this is nine thirty nine you got
aggressive sellers but by the end of the
bar look you've got buying imbalances
creeping in 29 52 for 63 so it's still
be short off these aggressive sellers is
make this pointless right because now
you got aggressive buying coming in and
then you go higher higher higher
here you get you rally back up to
unchanged and I don't change but the
open of the day which is close to
unchanged Delta scalper gives you a sell
you sell off a little bit you get down
here Delta scalp it gives you a buy and
that's where my chart ended
unfortunately real quick we'll take a
look at me now why I'm also I look at an
eight range on the mini Dow let me just
pull it up here somewhere make sure you
got the right chart here is this is the
eight range mini Dow and again you know
same things I always talk about you got
your divergence you got your ratio what
happened to my chart divergence and
ratio afterwards and you know you make a
decent rally from you know the 98 up
into the teens
then we're overhearing point of control
point of control up here up here this
one just goes sideways okay then we
start rallying start reeling get up here
you got divergence but that's it
price rejecter here we sell off on this
high get the price rejecter here rally
back up to a useful point of control up
here that's this aqua line sell off a
little bit and you start running into
these highs here so you got the
divergence there this is the Delta
scalper in case you
what this is this blue started this
green line but look you got divergence
divergence here you got just a ratio by
itself you know which isn't very useful
I do look for pull backs towards that
ratio that's your trade setup I have we
all I look for when you have just a
ratio out of high or low look for a
pullback and then you know towards that
high luckily it's short and just take
you know so even if you did that you're
getting short at 90 you got to move down
to 80 you know over the next two bars
are your rally back up but you know I
mean it's it's nine oh nine you got a
divergence nine thirty nine nine fifty
so within an hour you've already got
three divergences you might want to be
playing a breakout I mean you haven't
had a big move yet you know just sort of
stair stepping here stair stepping then
you finally you break it out here tena
what is that ten o'clock
do you get a move yeah you go from
ninety four up to ten so about a fifteen
point move before you get this
divergence and the ratio again you know
which is very powerful in and of itself
and you know so even if you got long
here and the break out around ninety
four ninety ninety five you're looking
at this ratio divergence you should be
covering it already in this bar so maybe
Brook even maybe I made a couple of
ticks and then what happens you sell off
from you know eight hundred all the way
down and you know below eighty and then
you just sort of go sideways in here
just really quick I'll show you just a
couple charts with the unique wrinkle
stuff again I get a lot of people asking
about uni Renko crude oil was a nice a
nice one well you know I'll talk about
Cruden on a footprint chart in a second
here a crude you know yeah this nice
cell signal up here from you know 4905
forty nine hundred and sells off almost
a buck it gets all the way down here to
forty eight ten area where starts going
sideways this was you know if you use it
are Union Renko try it's a buck move a
one dollar move there early in the
morning what I wanted to talk about
what's actually on the Nasdaq one
could pull it up Nasdaq II had a bunch
of signals some winners some losers but
I just dig it up here for you bear with
me
that's a beautiful chart on the crude
honestly I mean you know I mean you can
get one or two trades so you get two
trades and one's a dollar a winner and
one's a five cent loser you know I'll
take that I'll take that every day
unfortunately it's not always like that
now here's the Nasdaq uni Renko chart so
I'll just take it back again you know
Nasdaq realistically you should be
looking to trade it drink after the cash
open here at 8:30 I mean yeah you got a
trade here that worked out you know one
that didn't this one you know didn't I
got nothing before that so what do you
got you got a nice little move here this
one fails then you get a nice move here
you know from the 47 area down into the
37 area you know then again the other
sell then you get a buy here you know
kind of works out a little bit small
winner this one sideways and then pops
up before selling off and then down here
you get some buy signals but again you
know can you take you know a small loss
like this when you're getting you know
you're you're losing basically one bar
but like here you're getting how many
one two three four five six bars you
know here you're getting ten bars you
know that that's yet to ask yourself in
trading yeah you're risking basically
one bar but if you're getting moves like
this with 10 or 15 bars you know eight
or nine bars you know that's what you
want if you're risking one bar to get
eight or nine back okay let me see if I
can find the crude oil footprint chart
really quick
okay so make sure I got the right one
with the indicators on them I had a lot
of crudo charts open again you know
crude is something I get a lot of
questions on as well well let's just
show you this one really quick just some
I got different indicators on not all of
them have all the exact same things
running on but you know the main ones
are the Delta scalper and the and the
price rejector you know just really
quick this is the 987 tick charting
crude with the Delta scalper yeah nice
move here again you also captured that
move here from 49 bucks down to 48 2048
30 so you got a nice little move here
nice little back up then a nice move
down
that's a 1987 tick chart Delta scalper
and price rejector do run on normal bar
charts okay I think this is the chart
here that I'm looking for that's got
everything to see price rejector well
they both do actually so they just walk
it back a bit here earlier in the
morning okay so you know what you got
you had divergence here you got the
price rejector in the next bar Delta I
sorry it's not price rejected is Delta
scalper this is the Balto's transition
this yellow thing which is also bullish
start rallying up here Delta scalper
gives you a sell you know here you got a
stack my imbalance and unfortunately
smart it just kind going sideways here
then he starts selling off again whoops
down into new lows you break through the
low you know you notice you're not seen
a divergence is yet here here here you
got one down here this is around the
4850 area got a nice stacks on a balance
just you know as you're breaking out you
know that's me that's bearish again I'd
rather have the selling and balance down
here as you after you're on the other
side of the below rather than going into
the low that's me though people get its
arguments that where it's where is it
better I know from my own analysis that
it's better down there
here you got a failed divergence here
you know that failed divergence so again
you get three failed divergences
relatively quick although you already
just had a move right it would look a
lot better if you had failed divergence
here oh maybe one here then one here not
as you go down from 4860 all the way
down to you know 48 16 you know it's a
50 cent movie gets filled three failed
divergences yeah you can play it i mean
i don't know how much of this move is
left honestly here you get a buy the
delta scalper coming in and it just
comes right back on you really quick you
know you say you break off that low so
you didn't you know take out the third
failed divergence I mean did you get a
big movie and I really you got a lot of
10 cent move then you just started going
sideways sideways sideways you get
within a tick of the low here you don't
hit it you know you got a big step
behind in balance coming in here at
10:11
did it work out yeah it kind of did you
know it sits on the right side but this
bar here the third bar it's not good
when you start coming back you know the
third bar and fourth bar you're on the
other side you know it's it's not good
you know I mean yeah at this point how's
it doing it's a little bit higher than
the fifth bar but you know you're
looking for the move and it should be
happening within the first three bars
not all it comes up and then sells off
below the imbalance and then back up
again no that's that's not what you want
definitely not what you want so anyway
thanks for watching this presentation be
sure to subscribe to our YouTube channel
and you know if you want to learn more
about order flows and the order flow
software visit order clothes calm and if
you wanna learn more about the Delta
scalper go to Delta scalper calm you
know that's what you want to do and be
sure to subscribe to my youtube channel
I try to get these channels updated
every day you know with the video or two
some days I get to up there and you know
they're gonna help you're learning in
trading so I got something else coming
out later this weekend hopefully so stay
tuned and subscribe to my channel guys
thanks and have a great weekend